One of the things that happens to people
all the time in their life is they get
to where they're going and then
they don't know what to do,
right?
So for example,
you graduate from university,
it's like,
okay,
story over.
Who are you now?
Who are you the next day?
And so,
so what happens is when you succeed,
then there's a success crisis
and the success crisis as well.
I've run this story to its end now what?
And that's exactly what happens
in the Abrahamic stories.
And there are punctuated by a period
of contemplation and sacrifice.
So every time an Abrahamic
story comes to its end,
then Abraham makes another
sacrifice and communes with God,
and then he figures out what to do next.
And that seems,
that seems right.
It seems psychologically right?
Because what you should do when
your story comes to an end,
when you've achieved what it
is that you want to achieve,
or perhaps when you're in
terribly dire straights,
but we won't talk about
that at the moment.
When you've achieved
what you need to achieve.
Then the next question is,
okay,
well now I'm that person,
or I have that character.
What?
What do I need to do next?
And some of that is always,
well,
what do I need to give up now?
What do I need to let go of so
I can move to the next plateau?
Right?
As soon as your life as a,
hopefully a,
a sequence of upward moving,
what would you call them?
It's like scissor office.
Except you're actually,
each time you climb up the mountain,
you get a little higher on the
mountain at something like that.
So it says office with
an optimistic bent and,
and,
and maybe if you push the rock up the
mountain properly and let it roll down
then.
And if you do that right,
then it's okay.
Every time you roll it back up,
it's,
it's better in some sense.
And I don't think that's
unrealistic either.
And so,
well.